the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to round two of the
2022 spring chess classic i'm
grandmaster alejandro ramirez here with
grandmaster christian carilla to bring
you all of the action always a pleasure
to be here with you in the studio
alejandro welcome oh it's a pleasure to
do commentary with a good friend and we
have an exciting event for you might not
be the same field cup it might not be
the u.s champs but it's an important
stepping stone for many young and
aspiring players to become stronger a
lot of them are trying to break into the
2700 group and this is an excellent
tournament for them to gain rating and
to practice and what an amazing first
round we had yesterday alejandro all the
players came very well prepared we've
seen a lot of improvements in all phases
of the game we saw some brilliant ideas
in the opening i remember that idea of
sam savion with the early e4 we saw some
brilliant play in the end game from
jeffrey shong as these players were
easing into the tournament and now in
round number two we have a lot of
excitement on the board let's catch you
up on what happened yesterday as we have
these standings after round number one
in the a group it was only young jeffrey
shark that was able to pull off a
victory he did it against misha on tip
of a very clean win in that scotch game
meanwhile we had draws that really
favored one side i would say that the
biggest miss of the day was certainly by
dario schwertz who had a totally winning
position against kamil dragoon but
missed a simple tactic and a perpetual
was forced on the board and another very
interesting game was the one between ray
robson and hans niemann with the pendle
room swinging on both sides absolutely
both sides not really having a chance to
win that one it was a very fun game
let's take a look at the standings in
the b group here we had more decisive
results elsa maria de body christopher
you and chris rapko were all able to
defeat their opponents and they sit on
position number one at the expense of
robert hungaski who is actually uh the
rating favorite going into this event at
25 54. jj alimorandi and harshid raja
unfortunately for them started with a
loss
absolutely and we'll see the players
there in action let's take a look at the
format of this event we have two 10
player round robins and classical chess
time control is 90 minutes before he
moves you get an extra 30 minutes when
you reach mu 40 and all throughout a 30
second increment and the players may not
mutually agree to a draw in less than 40
moves this is going to guarantee a very
combative tournament i like that rule a
lot i think that it forces the players
to strategize differently as they can't
just drop the white pieces and claim a
draw and let's go through the schedule
as well alejandro we started yesterday
with round number one every single round
from now until the eighth round
including the eighth round will start at
1 p.m central time the last and final
round thursday march 10 is going to
start two hours earlier at 11 a.m
central time and after that we're going
to have playoffs if necessary of course
if the we have a tie for the first place
we will be having those playoffs and uh
you can also reach us and ask us any
question and we're going to try to
answer it during the broadcast you can
find us on twitter at hashtag
springchessclassic absolutely join in on
the conversation we're going to be
checking out our twitter to see what the
questions are are and let's take a look
at what we have in store for you today
as we have the parents for the a group
we see sam savion playing against misha
antipo of iliya nishnik facing against
young hans niemann aram hakobian playing
against camille dragoon this is a battle
of collegiate chess around hakobian of
course representing webster university
and kabil dragoon representing the
national champions in ut rgb university
of texas rio grande valley ray robson
who graduated from webster is playing
another player that graduated from
western alex slenderman and darius fears
is facing against jeffrey chong this is
certainly the matchup of the day young
jeffrey was the only victor yesterday
they faced each other several times
through the last few months
in very major tournaments they played
each other in the sing field cup they
played each other in the us chess
championship and now they are measuring
against each other yet again here at the
st louis chess club we're gonna
certainly be putting an important
emphasis on this game let's take a look
at the b pairings
robert hungask is trying to make his
bounce back against armand mihalyan jj
ali marandi is doing the same against
abhimanyu mishra meanwhile raja harshit
also trying to bounce back from his loss
by playing against chris repka those two
are of course teammates as they study
under the tutelage of grand master
christian kirilla at the university of
missouri
sanghanin is playing as el shamuran de
bati and christopher yu is playing
against titus tarmovichus christopher
you with a nice victory yesterday
against fungoski certainly proved that
he has technique from the opening all
the way to the end game titus a very
dangerous opponent who is specializing
in very sharp sicilians with the black
pieces unfortunately for us that game is
already done christian tell us a little
bit about what happened in that one
speaking of very sharp sicilians
alejandro this is exactly what we had
today in that game that finished while
uh these players were getting ready in
the first two and a half hours we had
the game between christopher u and tita
stroma vitrus the key game of group
number b let's see how that played out
e4 c5 knight f3 knight c6 d4 cd4 an open
sicilian knight takes d4 knight f6
knight c3 and now this move e6 of course
black can play e5 that's going to
translate into the swesnikov they can
even play the move d6 a lot of options
but he decides to go with this move e6
now we see the move a3 a very intriguing
decision of course e6 immediately is
trying to bring this bishop to b4 and
create this pin against the knight on c3
putting direct pressure on the pawn on
e4 there are a couple of ways in which
you can avoid that one of them would be
to try to immediately create a direct
attack with the move knight to b5 trying
to swing this knight all the way to d6
with a check now black has a couple of
options one of them being a d6 which is
most likely going to transpose into a
vashnikov after knight to bishop to f4
e5 bishop to g5 and now we have the
topia of the juvenile variation of
course black also has the option of
playing the move bishop to b4 which
leads to very very intriguing positions
instead of that
white decided to immediately sidestep
from all these main lines with the move
a3 and now we have bishop to e7 knight
takes c6 b takes c6 and immediately a e5
knight to d5 we see this uh knight
centralized square for uh the knight uh
protected by both pawns on c6 and e6 a
very nice position for the knight we see
knight e4 queen to c7 f4 and f5 and now
we have this position
and there was a very interesting moment
at this point after the move g6 which
was a huge mistake and of course it
seems like you're weakening the dark
squares of course i'm going to try to
immediately attack them well that's not
the correct decision actually he was
supposed to play the move queen to e2 he
played the move queen to h4 which is a
very natural move so
try and checkmate right you want to give
it a checkmate of course it's so
tempting but unfortunately this is not
the correct move he had a winning move
queen to e2 and the key point behind
this idea is that if you take on f1 i'm
not going to retake immediately on f1
i'm actually going to go queen to e5
attacking your rook and now you're in
big big trouble along the dark squares
if you go something along the lines of
rook to f8 i'm going to jump to g7
there's no more castle on the board for
you and now if you try to go rook to f7
well this looks like a perpetual right
i'm going to go queen g7 you're going to
go rook f7 no no no i can attack this
checkmate uh with
with the tempo by taking the pawn on h7
as well everything falls in black's
position this is just game over he
missed this opportunity he played the
move queen to h4 and after that we
entered this end game in which black
understood very well this particular
position right now after rook to a4 rook
takes a4 b takes a4 it seems like the
white king is going to go all the way to
a5 b6 and the pawn will promote but the
key in the position is that once your
king reaches the square a5 i'm just
simply going to place my bishop on this
diagonal d1 a4 i'm going to attack your
pawn on a4 and you're not going to be
able to move the king anywhere to
support the push of this pawn and the
players played a few more moves but they
soon agreed to a draw
a draw in this game very interesting
game but uh it finished in the draw i
think it's so easy to move miss this
kind of moves queen e2 knight takes f1
your mind immediately thinks well i have
to recapture the knight on f1
immediately and then black has
possibilities but this queen e5 queen
design what a beautiful concept
unfortunately missed there by
christopher you but a fair draw there
let's take a look at the price from why
the players are in this tournament's not
just experience and last there is a
serious amount of money here at stake uh
in the a group this is the way of
supporting upcoming chess players six
thousand dollars for first price four
thousand dollars per second uh the
prices are split except for the first
price those are actually decided on a
playoff and meanwhile in the b group we
have slightly lower prices with four
thousand being first 2500 on second and
third at 2 000 speaking of the b group
let's take a look at a game that is
certainly close to finishing as we have
over there uh
jj alimorandi not at the board waiting
for his opponent abiwan yu mishra the
youngest grand master in history but not
having a successful day here as his
pieces simply have no coordination it's
true that he's currently up upon we can
take a look at this position
but that's just about the only good
thing his king on e7 is in dire straits
these rooks are doing absolutely nothing
crashing against the pawns
uh these bishops are taking the queen
side nothing to defend there and these
beautiful rogues are well coordinated
and keeping black at bay so by all
stretch of the imagination this is
absolutely hopeless for black we expect
jj to collect this point relatively
quickly and i'm actually wondering
christian if you have it up what was the
mistake here
from the young grandmaster it seemed
like he was under pressure yes he was
yes he was so we've seen this position
starting from the beginning with this
idea uh against the triangle set up for
black with g3 immediately giving up upon
for the initiative uh this uh sort of
ideas of giving up upon early uh in uh
this particular opening seems to
resemble some clashes in the world
championship match between uh magnus
carlsen and jan nepomnyashi so we're
seeing a lot of players with the white
pieces just saying okay take my c4 pawn
i'm just going to maneuver around here
i'm going to push my pawn in the center
as we're seeing in the game
and then i'm going to play for long term
initiative this is exactly what we're
seeing in this game knight to g5
transferring the not transferring the
knight to e4 getting ready to jump
potentially to a d6
and uh i'm trying to figure out exactly
where the big mistake uh was but it
already seems quite difficult because
sure you are some material up but you
have a lot of weaknesses and you don't
have where to place your king of course
you cannot go on the queens side but
also if you try to go on the king side
well i'm going to destroy you destroy
your pawn structure in front of your
king and checkmate you very quickly on
the king side so you're kind of the in
this limbo where am i going to put the
king and if you cannot move the king
well you're not going to be able to make
the connection between the rooks you're
not going to
be able to harmonize your pieces so
after g5 we see this position king to e7
but sure yeah do you want to have the
king on e7 not so much and immediately
white is uh pushing on the king side and
trying to create tension on this uh pawn
structure right here f5 queen to h5
tackling the weaknesses on this side
well you have to keep your rooks to
defend the pawn structure in the
meantime that's going to allow me to
invade on the other side and this is
exactly what we're seeing well this
position seems to be kind of hopeless it
just seemed like a very slow but a
decisive build up in this game nice game
there from jj certainly the coach is
happy with his performance today good
good job student
yeah this this one looked very clean and
i i've been
wondering about this triangle setup with
g3 that you mentioned becoming so
popular and it's really
a sign of times changing i remember that
back in the day in the early 2000s this
was considered actually dubious
for the white side and it was considered
that the pawn could be safely taken but
now with our understanding of long-term
initiative it has become more and more
obvious that black's position is full of
danger chess is changing indeed at the
speed of light and right now we see this
doubling up of the rooks on the eighth
rank on the defensive side for mishra
but that's not going to help him the
bishop comes to b5 creating another pin
in the position bishop to g5 will follow
and that's going to be all she wrote
yeah this is going to be the end of the
game we have a couple of games that are
quite interesting let me switch to the a
group as i want to take you through the
game of ray robson and alex slenderman
uh certainly uh something has gone wrong
here for alex let's take a look at what
happened another one of these english
openings but this time with g6 and e3
certainly a very possible way for both
sides not very heavy on theory
but
raby ray was
on didn't find anything against the
groomfield didn't find anything against
some of the other alex slenderman
openings and decided okay let's go to
something slightly less theoretical
pushes an early pawn on c5 another not
so typical idea of the position a lot of
times they think this is a waste of time
but
in certain karakon structures c5 is
possible it's ambitious in the sense
that it grabs space ask black how are
you going to deal with my loss of time
well you see i was thought that c5 is
just not good in most instances because
black is immediately going to attack
that pawn with the move b6 but now
nowadays we understand with the help of
engines with the help of lila the ai
engines uh it seems like everything is
possible in jazz yes absolutely even
this scenario and
it seemed that anyway black got
i wouldn't say a fully comfortable
position but a playable one and i
started looking at here this position
and you're thinking yes black wants to
play b6 and once you destroy the
structure the remaining c3 pawn is going
to be a weakness and black's going to be
very happy but where's the time where's
the timing to do so because what ended
up happening in the game is that by the
time the black did play the move b6 i'm
already exchanging your dark square
bishop i'm already hinting at problems
that you might have on the king side so
i'm not saying that black is necessarily
worse or much worse in this position but
still not out of the woods when it comes
to solving all of the opening problems
still it seemed that the game was
reasonable for both sides here you can
see that white is transferring
pieces to the king side pushing h4h5
trying to get a lot more activity on
this side of the board but lenderman was
doing a good job holding robson back
even trying to create a little bit of
his own counter play here but it was
this decisive moment where landerburn
makes a very strange mistake you can see
that the last move by ray robson rook
ae1
targets the spawner on e7 puts a lot of
pressure you start looking at tactics
involving something even like bishop d6
or bishop g5 trying to
increase the pressure that you have on
the dark squares black never really
wants to play e6 for two big reasons
first the bishop on f5 lacks square so
you don't even know when a g4 push might
trap it and more importantly this is
like swiss cheese right you start
exchanging
the dark square bishop and nobody's
defending the dark squares
so the move queen eight to me is
absolutely baffling it's very shocking
because you don't want to un-defend this
pawn on e7 even if there was no tactic
in the position this is a strange move
to me that being said there is a tactic
in the position and spicy caterpillar
which is ray robson's handledonchest.com
never misses a tactic rook takes e7 rook
takes e7 rook takes e7 and i think at
this point lenderman realized oh i can't
actually recapture the pawn on a2 i'm
sure that was his idea
to me this is very strange because i
also think queenie 3 is winning but why
go for that this is actually a beautiful
checkmate you cannot take on a2 because
of rook e8 king g7 h6
and the king hunt is not even very long
you can actually choose which way to
checkmate the opponent
and if you're not able to recapture on
a2 you're basically just lost bishop
this is what i think he missed okay i
think he saw that idea of rook they say
to queen takes a2 but he said okay what
i'm going to do first is i'm going to
kick your rook away from e7 with bishop
f6 but he forgot that after rook to e1
you can play the plays the rook anywhere
e3 e2 e1 probably he thought about rook
to e2 he saw the idea of bishop to d3
displacing the rook from e2 and then
recapturing on a2 he forgot that this
bishop coming to f6 is actually going uh
to cover a key square for the king and
the king is not going to be able to
escape rook 28 king to g7 now it's a
checkmate in one move with the move h6
and rey was even more brutal after the
move bishop f6 he said why do i need to
move my rook as we mentioned dark
squares are very important here there's
not a lot of guard on the dark squares
around the king said my rook it's a very
good rook but you can have it if it's
going to cost you that bishop when queen
e3 lenderman took took
but i just don't see how
you're going to defend
all of these things especially with the
monster bishop on f4 coming to either e5
or h6 the queen is already very well
placed the rook is far away knight e5 is
also an idea knight g5 is an idea you
certainly don't have the time to take on
a2
yes up in exchange here for alex
lunderman but
this looks
hopeless again here for the black side
on a good day you sacrifice the exchange
and you're relatively scot-free but then
you will still be down your pawn your
king still will be weak this looks like
a decisive advantage well this one
alejandro is quite easy to assess
because what you do is just count
attackers versus defenders and white has
all of his pieces attacking the black
king has the queen the bishop the knight
and the pawn that's four attackers how
many defenders do you have well at this
moment zero the bishop on f5 doesn't
matter because you need to defend the
dark squares well right now that bishop
on e5 is only operating obviously on the
light squares so he's not going to be
able to join uh the the defensive side
the rook on the other side of the board
the queen on the other side of the board
is just a hopeless situation yes as very
well pointed out in opposite colored
bishops we know that end games tend to
have these drawings tendencies but in
middle games they actually become very
sharp because it's impossible for the
opposite color bishops to exchange
against each other in a direct way you
have to do it in an indirect way and in
this case black would love to exchange
that light square bishop for the dark
squad dark square one but that is simply
not going to happen
london seems to be
on
on his way to the defeat today ray
robson playing a nice game
yeah and you can see it on his face he
understands that he just simply doesn't
have any uh counter play at this point
despite the fact that he is in exchange
up the white king is extremely safe you
cannot use that x-ray exchange to create
any sort of attack against mike king and
that's the big difference in the
position your king is going to get
checkmated in the next couple of moves
that's right all right let's do a very
quick around the horn uh to decide where
we want to go next so let's very quickly
recap christopher you has defeated sorry
it has drawn against titus stamovichus
uh jj alimorand is currently up a piece
and we expect abhimanyu misha to resent
any moment we can pull up the board to
see just very quickly what's happening
in the other ones well i guess he
doesn't resign he wants to keep playing
down a piece not yet we see that move a
rook to c3 but there's an extra bishop
that's all we need to know there's an
extra bishop on f4 wow okay all right
he's fighting he is fighting he's a
fighter that's what uh that's what makes
so all of these very young grandmasters
so dangerous meanwhile in the game of
raja harshit against chris rapka here
we have an absolute mess
this one was very clear cut in my
opinion a little bit earlier but maybe
it's still clear-cut i think
this is a very strong problem
d take c4 is coming
and the pawn on c3 and the bonus and
absolutely i'm going to use that as a
decoy uh in order to win the knight on
e3 because actually you're most likely
going to have to defend it yeah probably
one hit the point is that as you were
mentioning if you put it you go this way
then c2 attacks the rook and this queen
is overloaded defending the c2 square
and defending the knight you can't do
both
this looks hopeless for
for white absolutely all right let us
continue just so that we have an
understanding of all the games very
quickly this is sam hanin against elsa
maria de body who had a nice win
yesterday against raja harshit
um
it looks
it looks like i can just take that point
on a5 right isn't that two pawns yes so
y is already a pawn up of course uh as
counter chance black has the two bishops
nevertheless it doesn't seem like there
are enough targets for those two bishops
in fact the only target that i can see
in the position is the black king
we don't have the queens on the board so
we are in the end game nevertheless it
seems like with two rooks on the board
and with so many files open up on both
sides of the board well it seems like
white is just going to be able to target
that king and as you were mentioning
alejandro just take on a5 what's going
to happen next
yeah perhaps there's still a couple of
issues because bishops are bishops and
they're very powerful it is an open
position
but it's certainly a two result game
here the player from texas tech is the
one
putting the pressure
and to finish up on the group b we have
this wild game between robert hungatsuki
and armand michalyan
not really sure what's going on it seems
like both kings are weak
not a lot of defenders around them
but hard to get to the
kings properly there is a threat on
queen takes a2 right now
this looks like a huge mess to me i
don't have an engine on so i have no
idea what's happening
is it time sacrifice rook takes d7 yeah
you start this is how we operate right
you you think how do i get the
initiative i don't want to waste some
tempo defending like with a3 or
something like that let's go
for the kill rook takes d7 distract the
bishop maybe put this bishop on c4 with
check
but then the king goes to h8 and it
doesn't seem like you're in time
because
the problem for white is that yorking is
not safe enough right either right the
king should be potentially on a1 that's
where he's going to be uh feeling very
very safe on c1 not so much because
after queen takes e4 black has this
option of cutting uh the king from
reaching its safe square on a1 by
playing the move bishop to f5 not only
that it locks that king on c1 where it's
going to be very very vulnerable but
also you're not able to create this
battery on the b1 h7 diagonal and create
the potential threats of checkmate as
white so the [ __ ] pawn five extremely
powerful piece and it doesn't seem like
white has enough compensation for the
lost exchange i agree so maybe this is a
little bit too happy
i would just leave this as a mess and
we'll come back to it hard to evaluate
this position initial impression i think
it should be about equal both sides
having good chances
let's move on to group a as we have
sam savion here against misha antipov
black if you counted it is up a pawn but
certainly not in the driver's seat this
bishop on c5 is a bit of a monster
defending the spot on a3 putting
pressure on e7 and making sure that the
pawn on c6 is just not part of the game
there's also problems on the king's side
as this pawn is being used as a
battering ram against the pawn on g6
upon h6 at some point might also [ __ ]
the dark scores around the king that
being said black's position looks very
solid it's hard to really put pressure
on any point besides the g6 one which
can be very easily defended by either
bishop f7 maybe even considering king f7
and
black i would prefer to play white
but i don't see an easy way through
christian no absolutely and uh well the
problem that i'm seeing for black right
now is his time management he only has
eight minutes for the next 13 moves
white on the other uh hand we know sam
savion tends to go into time trouble as
well but right now we're seeing him on a
comfortable 24 minutes on the clock so
that's a big plus for white in this
position black is the one defending
black is the one that is going to have
to make very important decisions as you
were mentioning bishop to f7 or king to
f7 which one are you going to go i was
checking with the engine and actually if
you go bishop to f7 you're almost lost
because of e5
no really i'm just going to uh create a
slow build up against your king the
point being that you don't have two
squares on the seventh rank and whenever
you're your king is going to get
threatened i'm going to go rook to b8
right
i like this move actually rook to b8 and
for example if you try to go something
along the lines of rook takes b8 and
height on g7 well uh tough luck because
i have this key idea of h6 giving up
that second pawn king takes h6 followed
by king queen to f8 and that's just
going to be a game over so you have to
be very careful right now we're seeing
michonne people thinking pondering his
next option potentially king to f7 has
to be played at this point so difficult
situation here for your student here
also a student from the university of
missouri a
very strong addition by the way speaking
of collegiate students let's go to mine
dario schwartz here playing against
jeffrey chong i really like his position
he sacrificed a pawn for the initiative
very similar to what we saw in this kind
of g3 slavs
you can definitely see the similarities
in the structure jeffrey does have a
knight on a6 a knight on d5 trying to
hold on to the position it
feels like if white gets in knight c5
and e4 you can put very serious pressure
here on black you also have the
possibility of taking on c6 i'm not sure
why that button would not be hanging
but what really upsets me
is darius really half a minute and 30
seconds oh my goodness
two minutes
two minutes after the movie much better
oh man this is going to be rough yes 20
moves to go 20 moves to go
you have to do something about this i
mean i've been trying he's been my
student for six years giving up
all right
next up we have aram hakobian against uh
camille dragoon
here we can count them up again and it
is the player from webster aram jacobian
that is currently up a pawn
and he has two passers against black's
d-file passer but this one's not going
anywhere if it ever gets to d2 it will
be swallowed up by the king on f2 and
one of the rooks
so this bond really needs to stay on d3
and maybe be protected by the move c4
but the moment you play c4
this rook is just going to jump to b4
attack this point i don't see how to
defend this weakness this looks
this looks pretty bad for black
in
yeah i think this endgame might just be
objectively lost
some techniques still required i
wouldn't say that black is completely
hopeless here that certainly i would
play on but
i think that aram should be should have
the technique to bring this one home so
we did see the ray robson game we still
have outlet slenderman thinking after
queen takes e7 and we have the only one
we haven't looked at so far between ilya
nishnik with the white pieces against
the rising star of hans niemann
and this one
feels like something went really wrong
for black just because of the way these
knights are located in f6 and h7
nevertheless i am a pawn up you are one
point up i do have bishops it's black to
move in this position
how are we doing on time okay so we see
12 minutes for hans and thinking and 24
yeah 20 20 which which is actually a low
amount of time for ilia he's such a fast
player one of the most dangerous things
about ilya nishnik is the speed that he
plays it's like playing a mini nepo he
just blitzes out of his game and they're
all accurate very tough to play
practically against him
absolutely so let's see what if you just
simply take on e4 i was wondering about
that i think i do have to play the move
i have two options i could take
immediately on f7 well i am threatening
knight to c3 right oh you are 39 to c3
that is a very good question because i
definitely don't have bishop d5 this is
important because the move knight c3
forks the queen and the bishops that
gives me a very important tempo
and i think the key line that we need to
calculate is what happens after bishop
to c1
but can you go knight to c3 can you
still go knight to c3 i don't have an
option right here right if it doesn't
work i'm losing
yes yeah so you have to go knight c3 it
attacks this queen if you take on a3 the
point is that i give this check and then
i will recapture my piece this looks
very good for black you'll retain your
extra pawn i don't see any problems well
i'm going to take on f7 and you're going
to probably lose the e5 pawn as well and
maybe even the c5 after that so maybe
it's not that clear what do you do after
bishop takes f7
that's a good question
that knight is still a little bit out of
play
yes that is true
i am
i am wondering what i can do here i have
i have some kind of funny lines knight
f6
rook takes c5 rook takes p5
rook takes and was wondering if i could
made it at the end all about tricks
alejandra that's all i
somewhere or summer g3 i'm not sure take
on e5
check
here this is not made no no
this looks like a
this bishop should have a but what if i
just simply go h5 yeah maybe this is
actually just bad for black right
because i am threatening now bishop f7
bishop g6
that might be a sad checkmate and you
don't have a rook way to even a check
you don't even have rook a2 because the
bishop controls all of the light squares
this might be an important line though
because knight takes e4 is on the board
uh let's take a look bishop c1
knight to c3 and i feel like at this
point of course we have bishop takes a3
but do we have something we have some
other ideas as well maybe queen to c4
queen c4 looks very tempting i don't see
i don't think this works ever
that's not no that's never gonna work
so queen b4 maybe queen to b4 yeah
and not only that it defends the knight
but it also attacks my queen creates
this tension
uh maybe let's try queen to d3 because
whenever you respond with queen to b4 i
want to have bishop to d2 and create
that p
all right i like this move here
but i think he's relying on queen b4 and
after bishop to d2 you have queen to d4
check yes this is an important check
you'll be forced to trade the queens and
then i'm not sure which spawn i
recapture thing i think it's the e pawn
but i'll be defending my number okay so
i tried all uh
all the squares for the queen except e3
and f3 let's continue trying
one of the processes
that's that's that's the key all right
let's try it let's try this move
queen b4 anyway bishop to d2 and now
bishop d2 actually pins the
the knight and i don't have this move as
a check
queen d4 bishop takes c3 this queen is
defended by the rook so this doesn't
work
this looks good for white i don't see it
all right let me see what he has in
store right because this is the position
bishop c1
so knight takes c4 was played yes and
yeah we don't have a move yet knight
takes e4 bishop c1
i don't have another move right it's
knight c3 otherwise they lose a piece if
i go to g3 then i'm going to do exactly
the same queen to e3 and once again you
don't have a good way to defend both the
queen and the knight on g3 it doesn't
well are we missing so we might be
missing a couple things if this queen
moves i don't know where to put it first
if you go to e3 i have to calculate
knight takes f5 correct but let's put it
on f3 f3
the thing about f3 is that maybe i can
retreat my queen here but queen g3
always covers the rook right yeah queen
g3 covers the rook so this is not an
option
all right what are we missing then
knight g3 queen f3 just looks like game
over to me
um
this is the key position i think we're
missing something here we must be
missing something right knight c3
and now queen to e3 that was uh the key
move that we saw in e3 yes i like this
move
what are we missing alejandro
so let's go queen to a5
there's there's a there's there's a
reason we always made it to the b group
but we never made it to the a group i'm
not i'm not sure what we're missing i
think it's time to ask the engine
all right all right
and you
we do have a lot of games to look at
bishop to c1 is the right move okay
queen to b4 seems to be the only
response in the position and actually
he just wants to give up the piece and
play this position
oh and saying that right now i'm
threatening rook to b8 so you have to do
something about that as we expected jj
ali morandi has finished with a win
against abhimaan yamiche but yeah i'm
fascinating about this final position
that you were showing us there christian
it's a piece and pair of bishops but it
doesn't seem there's a good way for you
to unpin for example if you go something
along the lines of bishop to d2 then i'm
just simply going to double up on the b
file you have to defend with rook to e3
or you can give up the piece and accept
the fact that i'm going to recapture my
piece back but now after c4 you're just
missing uh
another defender so you cannot do that
maybe you can go rook to b2 but once
again rook to b8 and
how do you get out of this pin without
losing a piece you can go bishop takes
f7 and accept the fact that i'm going to
get my piece back but then you take this
pawn you're threatening checkmate on e8
i have to defend against the checkmate
and then we're going to have this
position in which it seems like
well white is very very close to
delivering the checkmate the king on h8
is weak but so is
its correspondent on g1 that's why i'm
going to play this move knight to g4
create my own threat of checkmate with
rook to b1 and it seems like this gives
black enough compensation so i think
maybe we're going to see something along
the lines of this one
it seems like hans has calculated this
position correctly took on e4 and i
think he's going to be able to hold on
and potentially make that draw what a
beautiful resource it's very easy to
analyze the position bishop c1 you start
looking at the night jumps that's always
the first instinct you want to preserve
the piece but a beautiful find there
trying to not retain the piece just give
it away and say the final position
there's still problems for white in
terms of coordination very very nice
resource here by hans demon
all right let's move on to
i think we went around the horn
let us go to some of the games that i
thought were close to finishing
particularly this game between raja
harshit and chris rapka
we do see the move rook f3 on the board
i am trying to figure out what is the
problem with d takes c4
i guess you just take back with check
but still oh the takes before i take
back with check and this this rook is
hanging of course
even this is not i'm not sure that white
survives it but
this is probably completely unnecessary
is there a direct win we're looking at
moves like c2
c2 looks very powerful to start with
this move instead
you are attacking the rook the knight
cannot take because of the pin we
mentioned you cannot take with the queen
because bishop takes e3
and if you move the rook anywhere i
think that is the question how are you
going to play now
where do you move the rook though broke
the c1 roxy when do i take on c4
because if you take one with d7 i take
on e3 right so you take check yes you
only move yes king here and i'm
posturing that you can't really defend
this knight because you have to deal
with rook d1 as a threat that's a big
problem
that is indeed a big problem
so let's show that variation after queen
to e2 potentially defending the knight
now you can just simply take on e3 or or
you can go rook to one right away
does it matter
take take
and then that knight only three is not
going to have enough defenders
that's going to be a win for black so
let's go back a couple of moves
maybe i have to go rook to e1 reinforce
the defense of this knight on e3 true
though really wondering if it changes
much right
so i could take on c4 anyway and then
i'm going to take back
and then you take back with chuck and
then i'm going to
capture that one on c2 as well and the
question is do i have any way to
increase my pressure on d3 it doesn't
seem like i have anything direct no no
the queen is defending f5
and it seems like that shield of pawns
in the center protects me yes yes
it feels like this is not quite enough
so i have to be a little bit more clever
here so c2 rookie one is a much better
move
and the question is do i have anything
here
not so clear
so maybe we shouldn't start with c2 yes
why don't we leave the pawn on c3
right if there's no immediate tactic
then of course you want to retain the
pawn on c2 it's already defended there
don't put it somewhere where it can be
taken but what do we do this is a key
position by the way right now we see
chris rip
falling behind on the clock he only has
six minutes and 40 seconds left on the
clock
this is a key moment right now if you
make a bad move
you're uh you're you're going to spoil
the advantage
so we need to find something precise
what if you just simply double up on the
default i was absolutely looking at that
there were so many problems with the
rokan game many positions i like the
move rook fd8 dtak c4 becomes a stronger
threat in many many scenarios i think
it's a threat immediately even
a move like e6 might be met with t takes
c4 exactly and let's go through this
variation because i was trying to
understand what happens after queen
takes d7
you take back on d7
and now bishop takes e3 yes of course
you take back with the pawn getting
ready to promote that second pawn and
after bishop takes c3 i have the extra
move bishop to d2 yeah let's point out
that you cannot take this bishop yes
it's true that the queen doesn't get
back on time but the queen will pick up
the rook right how let's see it gets
back to d8 right good check this is the
only move by the way you the king needs
to get closer to the rook to defend it
you give a check yes you go
up i guess yes doesn't really matter at
this point you go check
and i think i can even staircase my way
pick up some more pawns so i get more
pawns i eventually defend this and then
you go to the 88 there might be other
ways to win this might not be the
most accurate or the engine way but it's
good enough we only need one way to win
and it's not hard to calculate so
yeah rook f8 e6 doesn't seem to work
and we see a move was played let's i
don't think it was rick f d8 it was the
move
did he play
uh he played
bishop takes e3 and immediately harshet
took back on e3 with the rook
all right why did this is a surprising
move to me because you could have taken
on e3 at any point the only reason i
would have like
done this is because there's a direct
win in this position so let's try to
find out the direct win
if there is one if there is one right
i'm assuming that he saw something here
is it like
d takes e4 well you take c4 i'm just
going to recapture with a check yeah i'm
wondering how to evaluate this though
you take on d7
and i take on e3 right
it feels like my pieces are getting
extremely active and
anytime you play the move c2 so let's
say you you even get with the queen to
support that move c to maybe potentially
get well actually
g2 king g2 let's go there's no you don't
have any traffic you have no checks here
well that's a problem because the rook
on f8 is not doing anything and you
cannot include it into the game uh by
taking on f5 because you're going to get
checkmated so you first have to do
something along the lines of h6 trying
to create a loof
you know the funny thing is i look at
this position and i feel that my
position was so good yeah why would i go
into this variation where i have to play
h6 if i don't have a direct win i don't
think i would have ever taken on e3 very
good question so i'm wondering
this is very typical right you don't
release the pressure on the knight
unless there's a direct reasoning for it
there's a direct advantage the only
advantage i can consider is that here i
force you to take so that on i can play
d take c4 it's the only thing that makes
sense to me i mean there's some argument
to playing d4 and now we see a very
experienced move uh by a harshit he uh
gets up from
the board and leaves yeah and lets his
opponent steal
right now in his own thoughts because he
only has three minutes on the clock
now he feels a bit more secure without
an opponent in front of him he's going
to be like okay i can take my time right
but no you cannot take your time because
you're going to go down to your last
minute and that's going to be a big big
problem going forward because this
position remains extremely complex
right it it's one of those positions
where your instinct tells you there's
something direct
and sometimes once in a while there
actually isn't you end up spending tons
of time looking for it and maybe you
don't find it or it didn't exist at all
and the tables turn quickly as you are
unable to keep up the position maybe the
move rook f5 is simply what he's trying
to do he played c2
really maybe d4 c2 or d4
he pushed one of his pawns he played c2
uh the move c2 is on the board uh we
think the move rook d e1 is
more or less forced here right you do
need to defend
uh this rook
seems like it so if you go rook to c1
let's just show that on the board i
think after d takes c4 uh the game is
pretty much over yeah because this rook
is always hanging
in pretty much every variation rook d1
as we mentioned also a problem even
though this is less clear than the other
line because you have king f2
maybe a couple more resources
but still looks hopeless right rook d2
coming the king is very exposed
but let's take a look at what happens in
the more logical route de1
and c2 was a very committal move very
committal and rook d1 played instantly
of course it makes sense to defend the
rook
well this is starting to get
very close sure right queen c2 is now a
real threat to the point where d takes
c4 i'm actually picking up both pawns
and i think white's better yes well
straight up better yes
so what is this white is going to be a
pawn up if i manage to pick up both
pawns it's going to be a pawn up and i'm
going to have a very dangerous pass pawn
on the e file
what is the i don't get it
okay he played something i think he
played queen to c5 oh is this what we
were missing
it doesn't look like it
it did play queen to c5 all right so
he's just trying to create a pass pawn
again like pass past e pawn part two d i
assume queen takes c2 the idea is to go
d take c4 of course the move d4
preparing a discovery doesn't work
because i can just block
uh this pawn
so this answers your question alejandro
why did he uh relieve the tension with
bishop takes e3 to create another square
for the queen to go to c5
yes
still i feel
that this wasn't the cleanest definitely
not the cleanest but it does feel like
black preserves an advantage here right
that pawn on the c file going to c3
supporting their potentially to get to d
to invade like that you have to do
something fast with white you have to
put your majority in the center in
motion i still like black
i feel like he missed the win yeah i
have a feeling there was a winner
earlier but
all right we can i actually do want to
go back i'll just cheat a little bit i
do have an engine as well
so just so we can move on
uh but yeah rook fda was winning in the
way that we saw but the computer thought
that bishop takes e3 rook takes e3
and still rook fda actually did not like
the move c2 as much
but still gives black a very strong
advantage not as strong as on the line
that we suggested but still
quite decisive i'm a little bit
surprised that it's as big as it says
but
doesn't seem to have spoiled the game
just yet how are we doing on the clock
here after uh the move queen c5 three
minutes and 18 seconds
for chris rebka roger harshit with about
15 minutes left on the clock plenty of
time for him
now we did have a lot of games that
we're about to finish as we started our
commentary we expected one to finish a
little earlier than it did but we do
have a winner of today's round my
student jj ali marandi here with
christian carrillo thank you alejandro
yes we are here with jj who bounced back
in style after yesterday's uh loss uh jj
tell us first of all how does it feel to
be back here in st louis and play at the
saint louis chess club it's amazing i
mean as always it's great to be playing
here and i was very upset when the
classics got cancelled due to covet but
it's it's great to be back and it's good
to be
bouncing back after a tough loss
yesterday and it's great to have you
back and your typical brand of fire
chest on the board tell us a little bit
about yesterday's game but also about
today's game yeah yesterday things of
course didn't go too well i wanted to
surprise chris out of the opening a
little bit but i think he surprised me
back
with a slightly unexpected move so
i mean i checked the h4 line actually
but i didn't look at the move knight f3
so i wasn't very aware of those
positions um and after the opening i got
a very unpleasant position and of course
it was very tough to to get back and he
didn't give me any chances so
but today i wanted to play for two
results uh a win or
an if i lost but definitely draw was not
in my mind so i wanted to bounce back
and i'm lucky and i got the prep in and
it worked out well let's get right into
the game alejandro maybe you can pull
that a little bit right your board
and take us through the game gg yeah so
lately uh
he has been playing the semislav and i
played the semi-slav like my whole life
so i thought that this g3 system can be
annoying at times if black is not 100
sure of how to handle it and uh he
played one of the most principled lines
of course but it's it's super sharp so
it's exactly what i wanted for today uh
knight d7 if yeah e4 it should be seven
although it says dubious it's actually
one of the it's the main line
and after knight d5 knight g5
yeah black can also play bishop e7 but i
think h6 is the the main move after
bishop e7 it goes on
with queen h5 g6 and so on
don't tell him all your secrets right
everybody's there listening and you're
taking notes yes so after h6
uh yeah the main move is knight e6 but
of course that has
a lot of lines where i think it's white
is still playing for something right
but it's too complicated and
it's like 30 moves of theory but i think
knight geforce is underestimated because
not that many people play it first of
all white is down upon
and but i think there is a lot of
compensation of course queen b6 natural
black wants to probably castle long at
times
and bishop e3 it seems like at this
point he was still within his
preparation uh he was playing quite fast
yeah i think he was surprised with
bishop e3 and uh there are only like two
three games in this position
and the idea is actually simply to
defend the pawn on d4
and i might want to go queen g4 queen h5
sometimes and the pawn on d4 has to be
defended i'm never afraid of knight
takes
e3 because f takes just opens up the f
file
and uh that's going to be a big problem
on the f7 square yeah queen h5 is coming
or queen f3 is coming
and it's very very tricky um
okay i in my opinion he played the most
logical
uh human moves and uh that is what i
mostly checked
and yeah here the move b3 i think was
important
where do you feel he's a big mistake
his big mistake
came at when after i played bishop f4 in
the game so i was still in my prep
until here and as far as i remember
after bishop f4 black has to play h5 for
some reason
and
i don't remember exactly
why what happens if i move the queen i
know computer screams queen takes h5
but
at the end it's a draw somehow but
i have no idea what happens if the queen
goes back
taking notes i'm never allowing my
students to play this variation
queen before rook ac1 and it seemed that
the pressure on both sides is very
difficult for black to deal with i like
that
despite the fact that black structure is
very solid it's just a piece activity
it's non-existent yeah it's like alpha
zero
and uh yeah i mean after queen before i
i was out of book but to me it's just
very unplayable to play with the black
pieces i don't know if i played it
perfectly but
it felt it felt good so oh i felt like a
very clean game yeah the move queen h5
the computer is not in love with but it
still gives you a huge advantage
and after this rook c7 it was basically
game over it's very difficult to defend
the black king and all the pieces at the
same time
yeah after bishop c8 i actually was
going to play htx g5 that i thought that
was the winning line after takes bishop
takes king d6 i thought rook fc one but
there's queen you want check and i was
super annoyed when i saw this
because after rook takes rook h5
bishop f4 i think he can play e5 and i
have three pieces hanging at the same
time and i have no idea like i can go
rook d7 i guess but why am i going to be
down in exchange for
no reason actually maybe a full roar
yeah he takes the king right
yeah yeah i was not happy when i saw
that so i just played rook fc one
immediately and i think at that point
the game should be over yeah the game is
by all practical means over a very nice
bounce back here as avimania wasn't able
to defend his position uh good job one
out of two not bad at all yeah i mean
it's
not bad clean game jj congratulations
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next rounds yeah hopefully we also
have another result as another
collegiate clash in aramha kobian versus
camille dragoon has finished in a
victory for the webster player aram
hakobian we had looked at that rook end
game and pull it up right now
with
that did look pretty lost we were
mentioning the spawn on d3 it's going to
be corralled if you push the spawn rook
before it's going to leave issues on the
pawn on the pawn on c4 and after d2 rook
b6 check the king doesn't have a good
choice if you go back to c7
then these rooks are going to
win the game
this rook d6 i think is one of the many
ways you can win but i think this is the
human easiest way to do it and this end
game with a passport on the a file but
the rook behind the pawn instead of in
front of the pawn is known to be quite
hopeless
although i'm sure there are many other
ways to win it after king d5 blocking
the rook coming here king takes d2 was
played and the rest was easy for
white and speaking of this game we do
have uh the aram with us to explain
exactly how he won this nice game
thank you alejandro yes we are here with
another victor of today's round aram
hakobian aram welcome to the studio tell
us how it feels after this important
victory for you
well um it feels great obviously
but mainly i didn't do much to be honest
in the game because it was all prepped
till i got the a7 pawn
so after that it was kind of easy it was
just made a matter of technique so
it was kind of a smooth game let's look
at the position as you were mentioning
so all the way until you picked up that
a7 pawn
let's see
did you feel like he was aware of your
preparation no absolutely not i think he
was
he was kind of surprised that i knew
till
uh till q4
and uh and we see right now on the clock
if i'm not uh missing that it's 15
minutes against one hour and 26 minutes
yeah i think actually at this point he
has four yeah 10 minutes right 10
minutes yeah
i think instead of a4 i could also take
on a7
but i thought that a4 is kind of the
killer move
explain to us a little bit why
well because if i take on a7 he can go
to k8 yes and let's say i go back bishop
e3
um king d7
and it's not so easy i'm pawn up but you
know he controls the squares king e6 h5
and maybe
and whenever you go 8.3 maybe he can
break with b4 and try to create some
counter chances yeah indeed
so after a4 i think i'm not sure his
best chance was probably to castle
what if he tries to maintain his pawn
with a6
a6 was a was a move but
takes
takes rook a7
and
he's kind of stuck i go just through k1
rugby 7 and uh
it's it's pretty bad he just cannot move
any pieces yeah if he goes bishop d8
something i go bishop c5
yeah this looks hopeless just lost
really bad yeah but
in the inclusion of a4 and b4 now taking
on a7 of course you have a pass pawn
that changes the dynamics of the
position making the conversion much much
easier
which are you actually uh did well that
was a very smooth game and yesterday it
felt like you got an advantage as well
with the black pieces against alex
lenderman it feels like you're in great
shape how do you feel about your ship
well it's you know two rounds and in
both games opening went pretty well for
me
so we
there's still like seven rounds to go so
we'll see hopefully i'm in good shape
yeah did you prepare a lot for this
tournament
yes
well and it's showing very dangerous
player certainly starting over at
webster university about 20 minutes away
from here one of the leading players
over there and certainly a dangerous one
for us
aram congratulations i'm looking forward
to see you in the next few days thank
you congratulations on your victory he
says he didn't do much but that's
absolutely not true there is a ton of
work that goes into these games and you
can see them over the board you can see
how much prep these players are putting
on you we just saw jj ali morandi
explaining his deep preparation you just
saw arabic
showing his deep preparation chess is
hard guys and you need to be very
precise let's take a look at the
complications that are arising in the
game between ilya nishnik and hans nema
this is to be what my producer is
going through a little bit of time
pressure but not too much
what is going on here
black is down
a piece am i counting that right
that's one night that's two vicious
i think i think you are i think okay
good uh i don't quite see
the threats wait so it seems like hans
did not manage to hold on yeah what
happened here what happened all right so
we looked at knight takes e4 bishop c1
and just as we were singing his braces
that he found all this rook takes b5
stuff he didn't find any of that stuff
he actually won for the move knight c3
and queen e3 was played as we were
mentioning we were worried about this
move actually queen e3 because you
attack the knight on d4 but more
importantly you don't allow this move
queen
b4 and d4 being check so that's why the
queen goes to e3 not to another square
we're being told that sam savion has
drawn his game we'll come back to that
one i guess ambition tipoff
but this looks like this looked to us
like a piece
and it still looks to me like a piece
and black is for a pawn but those two
bishops and you actually well you do
have the threat of rook to h4 that's
your only idea right you're trying to
give some sort of a checkmate
but there has to be a way in which i can
avoid that i mean even bishop e1 i just
don't really see
just retreat the bishop control that
square you're going to start fluttering
around with moves like rook g4 but
on the worst case scenario i think you
can start bringing the queen
and defend on the third rank and indeed
nishnik thinks like i do after queen h5
says well your threat's obvious just put
the bishop on e1 defend that important
square don't allow the rook to join the
fray on h4 it looks completely hopeless
it looks hopeless to me this is just an
extra piece and the powerful pawn on b5
makes sure that the conversion is very
easy
yeah i i think uh ilia is going to bring
this one home without any problem and
just to show you how that game finished
between sam savion and uh mihail antipov
because we were watching this game and
we saw on tipoff have only five minutes
for the last 13 or so moves and in quite
a difficult position at least that's how
it looked like at this point we were
considering moves such as bishop to f7
or king to f7 to defend the pawn on g6
but he decided to go a completely
different route with this uh critical
move and very concrete rook to d1
immediately threatening these rooks on
the first rank now if you take on g6 it
seems like white is just simply breaking
through and potentially going to give a
checkmate but after rook takes b1 you
can continue taking on h7 i'm going to
get my king out for a walk queen to h4
king to g6 and now my king is going to
be quite well protected on the light
squares if you recapture on b1 which at
some point you will have to do it well
i'm simply going to go queen to c2 there
is no way you can include this rook into
uh the attack against the king and
you're going to lose a piece because
this is a double attack you can't throw
in another check but i'm just simply
going to hide away on f7 and that's that
you cannot do that michonne tipoff
calculated everything very precisely
left that the pawn on g6 hanging play
this move rook to d1 and that forced
white's hand he played the move queen to
c7 rook to d7 now you have to drop back
to g3 rook to d1 we saw this repetition
and the game finished in a draw
fabulous resource there by misha and i
love the concreteness of this yes you're
attacking g6 but instead of feeling a
defensive maneuver he immediately went
for the counter attack and it paid off
solving all of his problems let's jump
back to this raja harshid against chris
repko game because wild stuff has
happened in this game
let's take a look as after the move
queen c5 we didn't see queen take c2 we
thought that position would be very good
for uh the black side but instead the
move e6 came on the board d takes e4
this seems very concrete queen takes d7
c1 queen this distracts this rook on e1
from the defense of the e3 rook so knows
no choice rook takes c1 queen takes e3
check
king g2 and now black doesn't pick up
one rook picks up both rooks this is why
this is so powerful but after e7 check
king g1 raja is saying yes you got an
extra rook but how are you going to stop
this pawn the spawn on e7 is currently
attacking the rook also gearing to play
e8 and of course if you just play the
move rook b8 or something along those
lines this is not just a recovery of the
rook that's actually checkmate so you
cannot even consider that
it feels like there should be a win
what you have to do right now you just
have to centralize the queen and play
the queen end game with a move queen to
e4 a centralized queen we know is
extremely powerful and right you do have
even if white manages after he takes f8
king takes f8 first of all i'm
protecting against any sorts of checks
on the e file which is extremely
important because it allows me to escape
with my king via f6 so for example if
you go queen to c8 king to f7 or queen
to d8 king to f7 queen to d7 then i can
just simply push my king forward king to
f6 and the queen on e4 protects
absolutely everything i love this move
yeah and you also it doesn't seem like
there's a clear way of
reaching that b4 pawn without allowing
my king to enter the play which is just
going to be game over
instead of this queen b1 was played and
the move king f2 came on the board i'm
wondering if he's considering playing
the same thing but
picking up this spawn on a2 check first
of course that does give me the option
of i'm going to hide my king after that
yeah you kind of do hide your king and i
don't get back to e4 on time i feel that
especially in queen endgames the value
of your pawns is so much more important
than the quantity of your pawns you
don't really need that extra pawn on a2
you already have the passer on c4
and once again he has to do the same
thing queen to e4 centralize the queen
and he does it queen e4 and that is move
40 i believe for chris repka yes a big
sigh of relief as he gets the extra 30
minutes
it still looks like a winning position
perhaps not
the best technique ever but still good
enough throughout it doesn't seem that
he
destroyed this advantage at any point
no
queen to e4 is a very very technical
move centralizing the queen and yeah you
just simply don't have a good way to
continue with checks against my king
because every single check is going to
push my king forward which i want it's
something that i want because i want to
get to that f5 pawn followed by f4 upon
and so on
and
there's simply no way in which you can
continue this game you will have to take
on f8 there's no other way to keep that
one on the seventh round just just to
point out that there was there would be
this idea of queen d8
uh perhaps trying to be a little bit
more clear but first of all i can always
take on d8 it doesn't really change i
can't do that but i can also pick up
some points you can start picking up the
phones you play check
yeah you just pick up everybody
so
this is just not going to work out for
the wide side as you mentioned in that
case e takes f8 is forced but not a fun
end game here for the white side
no you're a pawn down and i'm the one
with uh the past pawns and that is
extremely important spawn on c3 is just
rolling
yep and he takes on f8
which will be followed by king takes f8
and a long suffering here for white
maybe not even that long right
probably not probably not all right
speaking of that
uh let's take a look at what's happened
in the ray robson against alex london
game we thought that rey had a decisive
advantage when we left it off let's see
what's transpired since then he still
has a decisive advantage all right
bishop takes e7 queen takes the sevens
where we left it off f6 is not only that
but i think we just saw a resignation ah
well dressing nation there by alexander
will have ray robson in the studio soon
then to explain this game to us
uh let's jump to some of the others as i
think some people are still in time
pressure uh anything that catches your
eye christian
oh this fungus game actually catches my
eye
what is going on there's a king on f7
rook takes g4 was just played is this
just game over well it's just game over
yeah rook takes g4 we're gonna see a
resignation here because queen takes f2
which is the only move i can see it's
met with simply rook f4 check that's a
double attack on the king and the queen
on the file that'll just finish the game
uh so he plays on probably both players
in time pressure sometimes as they say
you just don't have enough time to
resign but
queen e3 i think would just force a
handshake queen three is easiest the
easiest but i'm sure that there's some
checkmates on the board probably but
you're not gonna calculate that you just
want to exchange the queens yeah the
professional way is queen e3 the
you know the
he's a professional i mean
he has played chess all over the world
he plays tournaments after terms he had
a good streak recently and he knows how
to finish those games and as you were
mentioning that just simply forces a
resignation yes and
sam there
um
sorry arm armand cannot be feeling good
about this game it was very complex
but in time pressure it seems that he
got outplayed we might not have time for
robert because we are expecting rey but
we will see
uh the end of this game in just a little
bit actually let me let me go to where
the decisive advantage decisive mistake
was because it does seem like this is
still very complicated you can see this
king is kind of weak on f7 but it
shouldn't be the end of the world
checking g8
i would like to coordinate to a
checkmating attack this king on c1 it
does give me some hopes for counterplay
i think if the king as we mentioned was
on a1 this wouldn't be the case but with
the king on c1 you can start seeing
moves like bishop f5 queen e4 unless you
have a direct checkmate maybe not such a
big deal bishop b3 actually trying to
transfer over the bishop to create
threats on the h8 square after it was a
very late move i really like that bishop
e3 move not only that you try to go
bishop to d4 and create the checkmate
threat but also rook to g1 is coming i
like this threat of rook g1 and here
perhaps in time pressure uh
the young player from texas tech was
unable to find a good way i'm wondering
if you have i'm wondering what well
probably the real there is no good way
no i like i like f2 i'm not really sure
what you play against f2 to be quite
honest with you the point is that i'm
covering rook g1 and if you take on c4
we have been talking over and over again
about uh the counter play that you can
get in this position with the queen f4 i
will at least pick up this bishop but i
think even like king c2 queen f3 might
be easier this looks lost for white so
i'm wondering why not f2
i like that move yeah that's that's a
very good move
well time pressure makes it full of us
all my guess is that he just uh didn't
want to defend the end game after queen
to d4
or queen before queen g5 i was looking
at
either one other one yeah and you take
take and you do you do lose this pawn i
feel this is a defensible land game but
of course it's white that is in the
driver's seat as they'll be up upon no
way to defend the spawn on f2
on time but after the move bishop e3
rook cafe queen e5 i have a
apparently this is a blunder
and after queen e5 i guess the white is
just about properly consolidated you
don't have this resource anymore
because there is no queen f4
and that means that both bishop d4 and
rg1 are huge threats unable to really
figure out which one actually f2 was
played he must be kicking himself for
not playing it earlier bishop takes f2
queen f3 doesn't help his cause and
after rook g1 the king was simply hunted
and then we got to the position that we
saw christian what do you have with us
in another game well i'm looking at the
game a very important matchup between
darius virts and jeffrey shang because
we saw the position at the beginning and
it seemed like white has a lot of
pressure despite the fact that he was
upon them from the early onset but
unfortunately it seems like black slowly
slowly um got his way back into the game
and now we see this position whoa rook
takes some madness happening in the
position of course after rook takes g5
you don't want to take back on g5
because right now is just going to be
potentially um a perpetual after queen
to f6 queen to g5 so instead of that
jeffrey says okay you took on g5 but you
have your queen under attack and the
rook under attack so i might as well
just sidestep this uh threat you can go
home
queen to h5 but that's just going to
allow me give me an extra tempo take on
g5 and then defend the dark squares with
queen to e7 that would be game over
darius says no no i'm going to take on
f5 i'm going to threaten checkmate
do you want to take the rook of course
not that's going to finish the game in
one move but i do have this inter mezzo
attacking uh the queen rook to g8 i
believe this is the position we
currently have on the board and
in fact this might just be game that's
like an extra rook
he might have just resigned because i
don't know he's still thinking i
i i see him on camera ah this is mu 40.
so he is getting extra time right now
yes it's very sad you get extra time to
contemplate your downer rook yeah yeah i
think this is just game over it is a
full work it's too much material
yeah this one went uh south extremely
quickly for before
we also saw it coming right
you saw the amount of time that he spent
on his moves
and you think uses unsustainable it's a
very complicated position
you cannot be spending this much time on
every move
and jeffrey
is an excellent calculator
he puts in the bait of the g5 pawn
and
in time pressure darsh is unable to
figure out if this pawn that's dangling
in front of him is poisoned or not
and now he is going to pay the price
he's going to have to resign this one
very soon
and this was the critical moment indeed
after knight to d3 queen to d7 right now
he only had 34 seconds and
you see e5 you see that weakens
the stronghold of this pawn on g5 and
you feel like you're breaking through
and you're going to deliver the
checkmate unfortunately it's just a
forced loss after a rook to g5 king to
h8 and now you're forced to give up uh
the rook quite a sad outcome for there
is weird spot jeffrey with a potential
victory is going to move on to two out
of two two out of two an excellent start
there for the youngster not
not unfamiliar with how to win this
tournament he's actually won the spring
chess classic a group three times
gearing for a fourth definitely a good
start there for the player from dallas
texas
let's take a look at what else we have
it seems that another game that might
finish very soon another one in which we
have a rook advantage for one of the
sides uh ilya nishnik is currently
playing against hans niemann you can see
that
this extra rook is
looks pretty free i mean you do have
some maybe problems with the move h4
coming
but i have the feeling that with such a
huge amount of material there should be
an easy or at least
comfortable way of defending a rook is a
rook
i don't expect hans to survive this one
that would be a nice win for ilya i
think he goes to one and a half right he
drew why don't you have lots of two yeah
yes
all right well we do have one of the
winners of today's round with a very
important one there
from st louis ray robson
we are indeed with a local superstar ray
robson after an incredible victory ray
first of all congratulations welcome to
the studio how does it feel to be back
here in st louis playing over the board
chas
uh yeah thanks it feels good to be
playing again also of course good to get
a win i mean alex is
probably my hardest ever opponent
considering raiding i think i'm usually
slightly higher rated but
i mean he's beaten me several times and
i think i maybe beat him once in our
recent games when we had like many draws
which was
a good accomplishment for me because
before that i was losing a lot of games
and yesterday also was a razor sharp
battle against hans nemos tell us a
little bit about that as well
yeah that was a very interesting game i
mean hans well we played a very
theoretical line which i guess was
expected because hans seems to be very
well prepared and uh in general
so we played a line where we were
actually following a game between uh abu
satsurah the world rapid champion and
anishigiri
and i think i deviated from that game
with the move g5 we both knew about this
game i just couldn't remember during the
game whether onix played knight d7 first
or whether g5
was played first
so i just kind of thought on my own and
i thought g5 might not be what he played
but
it should be should be a reasonable move
anyway and i think how do you feel about
the tactical battle that ensued towards
the time control yeah i mean
i missed one move of his queen a2 which
even though objectively i should still
be okay after that it kind of changed
the balance of the game and then after
that i was struggling because i was
lower on the clock and there was a lot
of pressure in my position and i play
the move c5 which
um weakened d6 which was a big mistake
and after that yeah he i felt like he
should be winning there
um
but he missed his chances he should have
been a little bit more decisive there
and yeah after the time control actually
i was the one who had chances and
actually had a few
wins they weren't super obvious but
um in general it was very unpleasant to
play his position so
yeah it was a little bit disappointing
that i couldn't win from that point but
on the other hand
it was good that i didn't lose the game
so i guess the draw was kind of a fair
result well yesterday his history today
was a much smoother game take us through
that
yes so
we got an um
a little bit of an unusual line i mean
he played one of the main lines with g6
and
d5 and the line i played against it with
h3 c5 is
is known but um normally white just
captures on d5 immediately but this is
an interesting way to play because you
stop bishop g4
and the idea is you want to put the
bishop on b5 and you always have the
idea to take the knight off on c6 and
you control
e5 very well and
yeah it seemed like alex didn't really
know this line too well although the way
he reacted was logical so castles
bishop b594 castles and i think this is
still the main line and i believe queen
a5 is supposed to be the best move here
most likely
um
but he took and he played queen c7 so i
wasn't really
super familiar with these positions
um i just assume white should be
somewhat better but i wasn't sure how
because
black
is obviously aiming to play b6 and break
up my pawn on c5 and after that
structurally it feels like black's
completely fine at least that's how it
felt to me so i figured i should try to
at least develop a temple so rookie one
bishop g5 made sense
queen d2
b6 all very logical yeah now bishop h6
was interesting basically i was trying
to scare
him uh make him afraid that i'm
exchanging darks for bishops is bad for
him and try to make him play bishop f6
or bishop h8
and i thought
in either square it's like a slight
improvement for me compared to having
his bishop on
g7 which is um kind of funny so he went
bishop h8
and then
yeah the whole time i've been planning
to play bishop f4 at some point but here
i realized maybe it makes sense to just
give up on the idea of maintaining that
sort of pressure and switch to the king
side so i took
and played h4 and suddenly h5 is coming
it's nice that i have this bishop on h6
versus the bishop on h8 suddenly his
king feels a little bit shaky and
i think here is where he probably
started to feel
some pressure and
yeah for the rest of the game i felt
like i was definitely the one putting
pressure on him i wasn't sure
about the objective evaluation i thought
i had some advantage but
um i think his decisive mistake was
definitely queen a8 we were shocked
about that movie yeah i i also
like i saw him he had a few minutes
before he had kind of reached for the
queen so i thought okay maybe he wants
to play queen a7
but i thought that was also a bad move
because queen a7 maybe just queen e2
and if rook takes a2 i have rook takes
e7 is very nice mate if he takes e2
i take on e8
rook takes e8 rook takes c8 king g7 and
i have h6 king f6 and
mate with the bishop
somewhere so
yeah and in general if he's losing e7 i
thought my position is probably close to
decisive so i i didn't understand
i assumed he realized that and then he
was going to make a different move but
then he played queen a8 which was like
even more surprising um yeah did you
talk to him after the game did he say
what he yeah it seemed like i don't know
to me i evaluated that he just can't
give up e7 um he did obviously
miscalculate something so after rookie 7
rookie 7 bishop f6 i was pretty sure the
only reason he could have gone for this
is because he thought after let's say
rookie one
that he could at least take back on a2
which he actually can't because i can do
the same trick with queen a2 rookie a
and h6 mate um
so
he definitely he did blunder this he
told me after the game so i could have
just gone rookie one and my position
should be close to winning um but then i
thought queen e3
might be objectively like much stronger
even more decisive yeah so i i thought
about it for a good while and then
um i went for i mean just in general
principles like the dark square
weaknesses in black's position me having
this bishop and my king is super safe
like it has to be winning but of course
i i try to calculate some lines
so he played f6 which actually didn't
see at all probably the best practical
defense
i think what i did looked very logical i
stopped him from going to f8 with his
queen so he's really tied down
um b5 i believe he played
knight e5 queen e8
yeah and here i spent a lot of time
because i completely hallucinated
something i thought he actually can't
move
like either his rook or his queen really
anywhere so i can kind of just do
whatever i want i can play d5 d67
and suddenly i realize if d5 he actually
has one move which is queen e7
so i couldn't find the force wind there
and i got pretty low on time
but it felt like i was still probably in
control um
with what i did but i wasn't completely
sure
it seemed clean enough to us at least
from the commentators booth
that it was just fully controlled
from start to finish
after d6 is just yeah e6 was a
yeah after d6 it was definitely over he
can't take his queen b7 and
otherwise the knight comes to e7 he's
just getting mated so after this it was
over just came down to the simple
principle of king's safety and
definitely your king was much safer than
his ray congratulations a very good
start for you and uh good luck in the
rest of your games thanks a nice start
there with one and a half points before
ray robson with a clean victory over
alex nanderman putting the pressure and
his opponent certainly cracked let's
take a look at what we have left i'm
curious on the hardship game against
rapcat to me that's the most interesting
one
it looks quite lost unless there's an
immediate perpetual this king on d5
seems like it's just running down the
board gonna be helping the spawn on d3
on c4 promote
certainly the queen on e4 is doing a
monster job of covering many many
squares
this looks over to me this seems like
it's going to be a um a win for
uh for chris rapko
uh a good start for him i believe he
will jump to two out of two 12 indeed
and i don't think there's another player
on the b group with two out of two that
i can remember
no because el-shan we felt was suffering
and raja is precisely the one
sorry elson is suffering and the other
winner of yesterday christopher you
actually drew against titus strom of
issues
all right we are ready with another
interview as we have another winner of
today's round a lot of decisive results
here in round two in the 2022 spring
chess classic we have robert hungaski
who won a very nice game thank you
alejandro we are indeed here with the
rating favorite of group number b robert
hungaski robert first of all welcome to
the studio and congratulations on this
bounce back how does it feel feels good
after yesterday's game i wasn't sure i
was going to get
you know a chance to come up here and
you know show a win or something it was
terrible
you started off with two whites and you
definitely delivered in this game how
does it feel first of all to be back
over the board chess to playing
overnight it feels great actually um
i've been playing non-stop since things
started to get more or less back to
normal like in november the tournaments
just started popping up again so i've
just been you know hitting it pretty
hard you're a globetrotter where are you
playing huh where are you usually
playing um well right now i'm living in
buenos aires so
i usually have my tournament circuit in
south america i just played some
tournaments in uh well buenos aires
brazil
cool well let's look at uh today's game
we're going to see that on the screen
right there all right
yeah
so through some of the key moments uh we
had quite the unusual opening but it
seemed i particularly wanted to get to
this complicated position
where it seemed like both of you had
weak kinks and it was very difficult for
us to fully assess the position
yeah it was pretty hard for me too
[Laughter]
um yeah i don't know about this g4 move
i mean i went into this line uh thinking
i could i could do g4
maybe something like b3 first and if a5
then g4 this could be a you know an
option because um
um maybe it buys me a little bit of time
but i know it looks scary you know just
creating that hook on b3 right um knight
c5 is coming too but i don't know he's
got to deal with f5 too so
um
and i was a little bit impulsive maybe i
didn't pay enough attention to this
possibility
interesting so i just went g4
yeah
and um
yeah at this point things uh were a
little bit i started to realize things
were a little bit more
tricky than i first thought
for example if i had gone f takes g4
instead of knight takes
he has this annoying queen f4 move again
and
this pin is very annoying and if i do
something like queen d2
whenever i eventually kick the queen out
it's going to swing over to a4 and all
of a sudden i'm the one under attack so
knight of c5 right now yeah knight c5 is
coming queen a4 it just looks like
black's attack is is flowing a lot
easier than mine
yeah this certainly looks very dangerous
for you yeah and and this attacking
pattern of you know bishop on e6 knight
c5 and queen on on a4 is something
that's going to happen later in the game
that's right we did see it after knight
takes g4 queen f4 check rook d2 e4 was
played
yeah and after bishop g3 queen g5 it
does it wasn't quite a four but it does
also allow the queen to transfer over to
the queen's right yeah kind of a similar
idea so yeah maybe this h4
i don't know um it just seems to help
his queen you know swing over
to the queen side maybe i should have
just gone queen takes e4
but that also looks kind of sketchy
after bishop to f5
or
knight to c5 knight c5 was was something
i was i was worried about
i'm worried about every movie
yeah yeah so i was kind of uh
disappointed you know i thought i was
gonna be the one attacking and all of a
sudden it get turned turned around on me
but you had to do it very well after h4
you first played this really nice move i
liked it it the bishop on e2 not a very
valuable piece in your arsenal at the
moment and it allows your rook to come
to d7 and now again a double-edged
position in which both sides are
attacking yeah basically i was like i've
had enough of this knight coming to c5
i'm just going to get rid of it besides
we're very low on time at this point
yeah
i don't know if bishop c4 might be the
only move there because there were there
were a lot of moves i was looking at
they all looked terrible for me yeah and
um here
i was very surprised he played queen f5
i think this is a bad move
uh i was expecting rook f7 immediately
trying to exchange this rook yeah um
because i'm threatening rook takes g7
followed by oh sorry uh yeah so things
like some bishop e5 ideas and queen e4
it looks scary yeah
the game starts to take an interesting
turn here because
uh this theme of the opposite color
bishops starts to you know become
important right um
and actually if he had gone to rook f7
maybe you guys can can help me figure
out what's going on here because i was
looking at rook takes
bishop takes
f takes e4 and after queen takes a2
and um
here i think he has to go queen a1
and he's probably going to be a troishan
game right i don't know queen b1 takes
king takes and he has this bishop g6
move oh oh
yeah
where i missed that move
and um i think that's the position after
g1
rook g1 i think he just takes and then
takes on e5 that's just going to be a
pawn up yeah and goes king h7 i don't
think i have any good discoveries there
yeah i agree um so i was looking um i
mean
i was talking a little bit with my
opponent after the game i think i have
to go like rookie one there after bishop
g6 yeah
but then i think he can just go a rookie
eight i like rookie eight it's a yeah
because you're going to drill on e4 it's
going to be well maybe you can go knight
to f6
i have a nine out of six here sorry no
but even if you just go king takes right
and i go would i have to go knight f2
that looks very sad no knight f6 b4
after rook to e8 they just tried to get
into some sort of a opposite color
bishop yeah that that's probably my my
best bet yeah but he wasn't looking he
wasn't looking for a draw he was trying
to win just a second can you go king to
h8 or even king to f8 right now here
yeah oh oh and trapped the knight no no
king to f8 yeah yeah i like this one
better knight takes and the point is
that after bishop takes c5 actually the
knight is trapped nice very nice
i like this variation a lot yeah perhaps
uh the rook f7
tempo was important and swinging the
queen to f5 actually another more that i
see it more it is a strange move because
the queen was so active on a5 i always
want to take on a2 he told me he missed
queen d2 and uh queen d2 is kind of a
game changer because now i'm definitely
threatening rook takes g7 oh my queen
takes h6 and all that stuff yeah but
still he had some chances
to survive and it seemed that his
decisive mistake came even a little
later
here in this position did you consider
the move f2 immediately
um
i don't think so i mean i think i had
like 30 seconds here all right
stuff yeah
i'm threatening rook g1 and bishop d4
and it looks like a a really unpleasant
position for black i mean his king is so
open
yes we thought that f2 just basically
forces the transition into the end game
after queen to d4 because right because
if bishop takes now you have this check
on f4 right yeah
that's very important yes wow okay you
know i missed that
yeah we thought either queen d4 queen g5
could be up a pawn with
i'm not really sure how big of winning
chances and i can't do something like
nah i'm going to lose if i go like rook
f1 probably yeah rook f8 right yeah we
have rook fade and then queen e2 if you
don't trade the queens yeah okay
right yeah so so i have to go like queen
g5 you were saying or queen definitely
yeah
but i thought queen d4 take on d4 take
take and rook e8
and then try to swing the rook on the
second round king d2 bishop g4 right
something like that right yeah far far
from clear if black has quite enough may
have probably have to survive the end
game
but
much better than what happened in the
game of course after rook fade queen e5
it is lights out the f2 resource doesn't
really do nearly as much because of the
check a nice bounce back there for you
robert and
i mean it's been incredible to see you
play around the world that certainly
followed that tournament in montevideo
and it feels like your rating keeps
going up and up and up yeah we'll see uh
hopefully it'll keep you know i'll keep
the winning streak going well certainly
it is done today as uh you bounce back
to one out of two congratulations on
your win and good luck in the rest of
the tournament great thank you
all right let's update some of the other
results we have
a few games still going for you i
believe that dario schweitz is still
contemplating his loss
against jeffrey schon sometimes that
happens after
you hit the time control and you don't
want to face reality but a rook is a
rook
and that's just gonna be the end of that
game uh hans niemann is still down a
full
well you have a rook for two pawns but
unless there's an immediate trick that
being said
this didn't seem like the cleanest
still a rook is a rook i mean i played
my king to h1
and i have trouble believing that black
can really create enough
it's perhaps still requiring a couple of
technical moves
but
material is so big i just can't imagine
that this is going to be sufficient yeah
it does seem like black is getting some
sort of counter chances and the king is
quite safe surprisingly on h6
yeah it's it's a yeah it's a safe king
but then you realize that queen e8 queen
g6 is actually checkmate right
so let's see what if you just simply go
uh what do you want to put the king i
think
king h2 i'm actually thinking king h2 so
they run into some sort of knight f3
ideas yes let's be careful about it
let's get into that but
uh i also didn't want this to be checked
but okay king h1 is the more logical
move right right
and you go i think you go queen d2 or
queen f2 or queen f2
uh either way i do have to defend my
rook i don't have time for queen e8
because this is a check and then you'll
give a perpetual well i don't know if
you'll give up or batch you'll just pick
up a rook and try to win
um
you also don't want to defend that with
bishop to b4 because that feels like
it's uh taking the bishop on the wrong
side of the board yeah you never want to
put this bishop away from this diagonal
this does give probably an immediate
draw i think after knight of three check
yeah it takes and check on g3 that h3
did the same job and here you don't
escape the checks on f3 g3 h3 so i agree
this isn't really playable
so still perhaps some technical
difficulties right some chances for uh
black hans is fighting he's fighting i
don't believe in them but he's fighting
as we see uh alienation well let's take
a look at the results of today that we
have so far most of the games have
finished it's been a wild round it was a
wild round uh we have sam savion drawing
against misha antipov aram hakobian has
defeated camille dragoon ray robson has
defeated alex slenderman we expect
jeffrey xiang to be defeating darius
spheres very soon with the black pieces
as well as we expect ilya nishnik to
convert his extra work against hans
neiman after a couple of difficulties
and in the big group we have some
decisive results as well actually quite
a few decisive results we have uh two
wins by robert hungaski and ali marandi
with the white pieces against arman
mikhailian and abimanu mishra and the
win with the black pieces for chris
repka who moves on to two out of two and
he's the current leader of the
tournament also a quick draw between
christopher you and titus strema vichus
and we still have one game pending the
battle between sam khan and and el shawn
moradia but yes and well thank you
everybody for joining us here in today's
broadcast we're gonna finish it here but
remember tomorrow we start commentary at
3 30 p.m central don't miss it but the
rounds start at 1 pm if you want to
follow them live and some of your
favorite collegiate players here playing
or whoever you support so make sure to
tune in tomorrow see you guys tomorrow
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited